Today we are cracking down
on the massage parlors
here in Reno.
We are sending in our very own
Travis Jr. undercover
with these high-tech glasses,
which have a very small camera.
He will infiltrate
the massage parlor
try to get them to perform
the sex act on him
'and then we will swoop in
and start makin' arrests.'
[indistinct radio chatter]
- Okay. He's in. He's in.
- Ooh. Ooh.
Hi. You want a massage?
You want, uh, long time,
short time?
(Travis)
'Uh, the full,
everything you've got.'
'Uh, on the menu,
off the menu...'
- I give you everything.
- 'Everything. Alright.'
- Come this way.
- 'Okay. What do we do here?'
'This is my first time
in one of these places.'
First you have to take off
your clothes.
- Okay.
- 'Thank you.'
- I like your belt buckle.
- 'Yeah. That was my daddy's.'
- It's so nice and shiny.
- 'Thank you.'
You have to take off
your glasses.
- 'Oh, I'm not supposed...'
- I take off for you.
- 'Ok-okay. Oh. Okay, well--'
- Is that the glasses?
- Oh, oh, oh. Oh, no.
- I put glasses your down here.
- Yeah.
- Yeah. You look cute.
- I'm very careful.
Go right to the super deluxe.
Now, I don't know if there's
some kind of special code
I'm supposed to say.
No, no, no.
You get whole package.
- That's all.
- Oh. Ow! Aah! Okay!
Oh, God! What the [bleep]
- Is it, is it too hard?
- Ah. Ow. OW.
- Is it too hard?
- Oh. That's great.
- Okay.
- That's... Aah! Thank you!
- Oh. It feels so good.
- Ow! Ow!
- Ow! Oh, God!
- Okay. I now get some lotion.
- Oh, ow!
- Oh, good. Thank you.
Here you go.
Just put that right there.
- Okay. Okay.
- Okay, okay.
Okay, here we go.
Here we go.
[grunting]
- Aah!
- Ow! Okay, okay.
[indistinct chatter]
Whee! It's so much fun!
[groaning]
- Is good?
- It's great.
And now, happy ending.
- Okay.
- All better?
- It's more relaxing?
- Yeah. It's more relaxing
- That's great. Okay. Ah!
- Okay.
- Aah!
- Oh. Ow.
- That's better, right?
- Oh.
That's so much better.
So I'm supposed to get
on my side, or...
No. You just go on the floor.
That's good. Okay.
Is she dancing?
She's dancing on him.
- 'She's not dancing.'
- She's dancing on him.
- Aah!
- 'Get off me! Get off me!'
- 'Get off me! Ah! Damn!'
- Aah!
You know, there's more.
No, I don't want any more.
I don't want any more.
- Okay.
- I don't want any more.
- Just one...
- Oh, no! [bleep]
Just leave me alone!
Leave me alone.
It's such a pleasure
to hear on you!
Oh, come on.
Let's get him.
'Travis!'
Frank, Lisa.
Yeah, I don't think the cops
will be here again anytime soon.